this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming platform built by
all your favorite youtubers when you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
[Music]
we live in a world dominated by the
economic system known as capitalism
private ownership of the means of
production is the norm giant
multinational corporations have a
greater gdp than entire countries and
we're currently witnessing the birth of
a second gilded age complete with modern
day robber barons and skyrocketing
inequality and poverty for the first
time in a hundred years the united
states is seeing a real resurgence in
class consciousness and criticism of the
status quo we've seen record numbers of
protests and rallies low-wage workers
are walking out and demanding better
conditions and the language of class
struggle is finally beginning to seep
back into the american consciousness it
would be absurd to look around and
assert that everything is fine that
capitalism is providing a good life and
opportunities for the average person
when every quality of life metric is in
decline for everyone except the top few
percent and yet as always there are
those who are unwilling to acknowledge
the reality of the situation and instead
fall back on ignorant or bad faith
arguments to defend a failing economic
system in this episode we're going to
look at one argument in particular the
claim that without capitalism there
would be no innovation let's start with
the assertion itself without capitalism
there would be no innovation what does
this imply it suggests that the sole
motivating factor for anyone to do
anything is money the profit motive it
suggests that the only reason society
has advanced is because of capitalism
this is quite the claim and as we'll see
shortly it is incorrect in both regards
let's start with the first point the
profit motive as the motivating factor
once upon a time people produced food
not to sell but to consume themselves
and stockpile for the future no money
exchanged hands the end
of course this is an overly simplistic
argument but people who make claims
about the efficacy of the profit motive
should remember that capitalism is a
fairly recent development in the grand
scheme of things but leaving thousands
of years of human history aside even in
the modern capitalist era there have
been countless examples of people
choosing to innovate not because they
lusted after money but because it was
the right thing to do one of the more
well-known examples is jonas salk though
it was declared eradicated in the
americas in 1994 polio was once a major
threat to children around the world
polio is an infectious disease that
attacks the central nervous system and
often leads to paralysis during the
first half of the 20th century what
began as localized polio outbreaks had
reached epidemic levels in north america
europe australia and new zealand and in
1952 the u.s faced the worst outbreak it
had ever experienced infecting at least
58 000 people killing 3145
and leaving over 21 000 more with
varying degrees of paralysis in a single
year
some of the worst affected could no
longer breathe by themselves and needed
to be placed in what was called an iron
lung
this horrible disease brought
unspeakable suffering to children around
the world but thanks to a team of
innovative scientists led by dr jonas
salk today polio is little more than a
bad memory starting in 1948 dr sulk
dedicated the next seven years of his
life to understanding how polio worked
and how he could fight it in 1955 when
the news of salk's new and effective
vaccine was made public he was hailed as
a hero and a miracle worker sulk became
a household name he could have taken
advantage of this newfound fame and made
a fortune on the vaccine but he refused
to patent his creation
who owns the patent on this vaccine
well
the people i would say there is no pat
this is
could you patent the sun
jonas salk chose not to patent the
vaccine in order to maximize its
availability around the world by 1959 90
countries were making use of the polio
vaccine and by 1994 the disease had been
completely eradicated in north america
when people first learn about jonas salk
many of them are shocked that he chose
not to profit from his creation it's an
understandable reaction when the norm in
the pharmaceutical industry is criminal
price gouging where executives rake in
tens or even hundreds of millions of
dollars every year but if people like
jonas salt can exist in even the most
lucrative fields then the profit motive
is not the only motivating factor that
exists
and this is only one example if you look
around you'll find many more those who
benefit from capitalist exploitation
will try to convince you that people
won't be motivated to improve the world
without a financial incentive but that's
just not the case but enough about this
first point let's move on to the second
one the claim that society has only
advanced because of the profit motive
capitalist apologists have a tendency to
view the private sector as some godlike
entity that operates with a hundred
percent efficiency is the sole driver of
innovation and always acts in the best
interest of the people this is rarely if
ever the case in fact the private sector
hardly ever drives innovation at all
take the iphone for example fans of
capitalism love to say things like uh
you tweet about socialism from your
iphone but you wouldn't have that iphone
without capitalism that's a little
disingenuous to say the least if you
look at the iphone or just about any
modern phone really you'll see that very
nearly every critical part was developed
with public funding microchips gps
accelerometers image sensors touch
screens these were all projects funded
by the public either via the government
or the military and it's not just phone
components
nearly every aspect of modern day life
was funded and created not by the
private sector but by the public sector
satellites the internet public schools
national parks waste management water
infrastructure things we rely on and
take for granted today are the result
not of the supposed capitalist
innovation but of public programs the
private sector rarely drives innovation
even the internet's favorite faux
futurist elon musk is only able to
pursue his vanity projects because of
billions of dollars of government
funding
okay so if capitalism isn't driven by
innovation what is the driving factor
it's pretty simple really capitalism is
driven by the profit motive not by some
innate drive to innovate if something is
profitable it will be produced which
leads to the proliferation of cheap
useless garbage like 30 different kinds
of poop emoji pool floats and tens of
thousands of copycat phone cases if we
take the pharmaceutical industry again
instead of prioritizing new critically
important medicine the profit motive
incentivizes the production of slight
variations of existing drugs in order to
extend their patents in this way
capitalism actually prevents innovation
by demanding that funding be allocated
towards the most profitable ventures not
the ones that will do the most good or
drive humanity forward but this isn't
the case everywhere if we take a country
like cuba where healthcare is
nationalized we see a completely
different approach since they're not
beholden to the profit motive cuba has
made astounding medical advances even
with a drastically lower gdp than the us
not to mention decades of crippling u.s
sanctions cuban doctors are renowned the
world over and during the pandemic they
not only easily handled their own
outbreak they also sent their doctors
and medical supplies to countries who
needed the most all without the
expectation of any kind of profit again
capitalism will not produce results
unless there is a profit to be made
because of this hundreds of thousands of
americans continue to suffer while
countries like cuba make accommodations
for humanitarian crises with no
expectation of profit but let's move on
to something a little more current
i'm sure most of you have seen the viral
pictures of these signs put up at fast
food restaurants and other low-wage
businesses workers have finally realized
that they have some bargaining power at
least for the time being if you're
unfamiliar with the situation here's a
brief synopsis low wage workers are
quitting or not coming back to work
because they can make more money on
unemployment this has led to a number of
managers putting out signs saying that
no one wants to work anymore and
suggesting it's some kind of moral
failing here's the thing i don't know a
single person who would want to work a
low-wage miserable fast food job the
idea that people would want to toil
their life away dealing with awful
customers and doing thankless work is
absurd
this supposed american value of working
for work's sake is a myth it's nothing
more than propaganda by those who own
the businesses think about it if you
were offered the opportunity to not
spend 10 hours a day slaving over a
grill or staring blankly at spreadsheets
and still make enough money to live
would you take it of course you would
you could spend that time doing work you
actually enjoy or finding a job that
pays better that's the thing capitalists
never mention most humans do have an
inclination to work they just don't want
to work for you there's a difference
between work being productive with your
time and skills and the modern american
conception of work tedious labor people
are obligated to accept for fear of
starvation and poverty now this trend of
people refusing to work low-wage jobs is
a prime opportunity for capitalists to
innovate they could come up with a way
to make their jobs more enticing to
would-be workers have they done that
no in fact they've already run to the
government to beg them to fix their
problem for them and because all
american administrations are
increasingly corporatized we've gotten
this a threat that if anyone refuses a
job offer no matter how demeaning
degrading and miserable no matter how
low the wages they will be kicked off
unemployment so much for at will
employment capitalists can't stand the
thought of workers having any bargaining
power and so like with everything they
demand help from the government
capitalism doesn't innovate it only
pursues the next fistful of dollars it
asks where is there a profit to be made
it never considers the use value of what
it produces only the profits it can make
and so we continue to receive mountains
of cheap products that will fail in a
few months
the profit motive is not the driver of
innovation it stifles innovation it
prevents funds from being used in a way
that would actually benefit the world
instead funneling that money into
pointless often incredibly destructive
projects when there is innovation in
america it is in spite of capitalism not
because of it it's because people like
jonas salk realize that some things are
more important than profit the claim
that there would be no innovation
without capitalism is blatantly false
it's disproven by history it's disproven
by other countries it's disproven by
common sense and more and more often
it's disproven by the behavior and
actions of the capitalists themselves if
we really care about innovation we need
to dismantle capitalism and throw the
profit motive in the trash where it
belongs
if you'd like to learn more about how
capitalism has innovated all the joy out
of work i highly recommend you check out
happiness at work on curiositystream
it's a fascinating look at just how
depressing the modern job really is and
how it got that way curiosity stream is
an established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content and the financial
security of those who produce it they've
got thousands of non-fiction titles from
some of the best filmmakers in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well that's why
some of my youtuber friends and i teamed
up to build nebula so we don't have to
worry about demonetization as
educational creators ourselves we love
curiositystream so we've worked out a
deal where if you sign up for
curiositystream at the link below you'll
also get access to nebula 100 free
that's less than 15 bucks a year for
both curiosity stream and nebula which
in my humble opinion is a pretty great
deal since most of us are still waiting
for the vaccine why not spend some time
learning about fascinating topics on
curiosity stream or check out nebula's
original content including my upcoming
series on the resurgence of fascism you
can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free there really is
something for everyone and by signing up
at the link below you're helping us
produce more content without the fear of
demonetization give curiosity stream a
shot and get free access to nebula when
you sign up using the link below it
really does help support my channel and
educational creators all across youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes if you hated it go ahead and
drop a thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen thanks for watching and
i'll see you next week
[Music]